destiny 2 players alongside myself have
experienced an absolute renaissance and
its sweatiest pvp activity the trials of
osiris the change has been genuinely
unexpected and trials is easily the most
rewarding activity in the game right now
the reward system for the mode has been
completely reworked and we finally
finally have anti-cheat if you played
youtube i felt left out of trials or if
you were kind of burnt out on apex
warzone or maybe that call of duty
vanguard beta wasn't quite your cup of
tea then listen up because trials has
some [ __ ] to say
every destiny 2 player knows about
trials of osiris whether we're talking
destiny 1 or the revamped version of
trials of the 9 from the earlier days of
destiny 2. for those out of the loop the
objective in trials is super simple it's
a 3v3 elimination mode that ends once a
team wins a total of 5 rounds you can
revive your teammates if they die but if
they continue to get picked off then the
cooldown timer on the revive gets
progressively longer if a round goes on
too long an objective point spawns and
the first team to capture that objective
wins the round teams would go to a
vendor to pick up a passage basically a
scorecard so you can see how many rounds
you've won the ultimate goal of trials
is to go flawless which means you win 7
full matches in a row not just the
rounds achieving this would unlock the
lighthouse an exclusive social space
with some of the sickest rewards in the
game during the first year of d2 trials
went on hiatus since the game mode
needed serious work bungie stated two
years ago during season of the worthy in
2019 that trials was returning from a
hiatus and that it wouldn't be quote
half-baked on arrival spoiler alert it
was half-baked as hell apex and warzone
players especially on pc can sympathize
with the d2 folks because cheaters were
everywhere it was maddening even more
demoralizing is you had this like
ridiculous account recovery economy
where high school players would take
money from people to play honor their
accounts and earn them flawless rewards
and that was just booming as a result of
how toxic and almost insulting trials
was at the time the loot was good but
going flawless damn near impossible
unless you had a discord server full of
friends willing to carry you or a ton of
time to spend on heightening your pvp
skills that's all changed with new
alterations to the trials of osiris and
the season of the lost for several
reasons for starters your trials passage
no longer uses your losses to break the
passage before if you got three losses
at any point you could no longer use the
passage and you were forced to reset
starting back at zero the issue in my
mind was that trials matchmaking back in
the day used your card progress as its
main component so if you had a card with
two wins and zero losses the game would
try to put you up against the team with
the same record reset your card and all
of a sudden it's a blind shot as you
were just as likely to face a brand new
team as one that just went flawless and
started a fresh passage now however even
if you lose 10 times in a row if you
still have a couple of wins on your card
those wins will still be counted you
can't go flawless if you have a loss but
winning rounds and matches will still
earn you rewards so flawless isn't your
goal you still will find an incentive to
play and therefore keep the player pool
nice and plentiful going flawless isn't
the only appeal anymore which is huge
for the game mode if you play the game
casually or if you've just ran into some
bad luck with your trials attempts you
will still be rewarded through a
revamped reputation rank system gone are
the days of playing for hours hoping for
a match win just to earn a measly two
tokens and it used to be once you turn
20 you could go to scene 14 and turn
them in just for a new gun but usually
all that work would just lead to him
giving you a in tomorrow's answer rocket
launcher or something turning your
entire effort into a waste of time now
everyone gives you a rank up similar to
how crucible and gambit rank ups work
achieving the next rank will reward you
with the trials and grams straight up
which you can decrypt into a random drop
if you have some shards and glimmer on
hand you can spend that to focus the
engram into something specific that
you've already unlocked in hopes of
achieving that high stat or god roll
that you've always wanted another cool
change is that your passage doesn't end
once you've gone flawless see there is a
huge incentive now to keep playing on a
flawless card because every game won
after you've gone flawless has a chance
of dropping lighthouse level rewards
that's right higher level players no
longer need to keep resetting their
cards and getting tossed back into the
matchmaking pool on some poor
unsuspecting newcomers now in my case i
made the mistake of turning in my
passage after the first flawless of the
weekend and had to recline but the
moment my second trip to the lighthouse
was complete i kept playing with my team
and we got more adapt lighthouse tier
rewards in like 30 minutes than i had
for the entire six hours leading up to
that final run in the past lower level
teams would just constantly get stomped
on and eventually they'd quit trials
altogether dramatically shifting the
matchmaking pool now even if you go in
and are basically a punching bag for
streamers and pro gamers you still have
a lot of opportunity to obtain some
extremely quality loot of course you
won't be racking in the add-up flawless
weapons as often if at all but
high-level players are also no longer
gatekeeping the loot either the high
barrier of entry to get even a single
reward is no longer a factor if you
can't find a group you can now hop in a
trial solo to mix results depending on
the new skill based matchmaking system
if your goal is flawless you still want
to group for sure because your odds of
success going in solo are dramatically
lower now i'm sure there will be
outliers but the overwhelming sentiment
online is that running trials solo is a
very mixed bag but let's focus on the
fact that it's even a possibility which
is huge and is a huge boon for groups as
it means a larger matchmaking pool
before these changes the flawless loot
that you would receive was kind of
whatever too since once you got your
weapon and emblem there was like this
okay what now type situation a few
seasons ago add-up weapons were
introduced which were supposed to make
the flawless rewards meaningful and
encouraged teams to see their cards all
the way through versus playing up to
whatever loot dropped at the three win
five win or seven win benchmarks and
then just resetting their cards now that
skill based matchmaking is a factor it's
less likely that you're gonna face the
usual streamers or the dudes with the
2500 plus elo rating this weekend a lot
of my friends made it to flawless for
the first time and their overall katie's
were well under 1.0 and that is a good
thing i've seen a lot of folks on
twitter complain about skill-based
matchmaking and they're not the pros or
the average players they're usually the
dudes that made a killing by charging
for recoveries and then just stomping on
weaker players and now they actually
have to work for it they're starting to
quake a little bit some of the pro
players though like giggs on the other
hand know their own skill level and are
confident that having a harder challenge
is totally fine and they're still
excited to see players who used to be on
the outside looking in get their
legitimate shot at making it to the
lighthouse that's why everyone needs to
play trials as soon as they can keep the
game mode filled to the brim with
players and earn some sick rewards while
you're at it the messenger and igneous
hammer are two superb guns for all
around crucible play within the current
meta and they can even drop with the
newer perks that have only just come out
this season which makes the sandbox real
interesting to play around with i know
everyone loves kill clip but that gets
boring we've said for years to bungee
that we don't just want more loot we
want better and more interesting loot
since more loot simply means more
garbage in the vault and having the new
perks roll on the trials weapons while
letting players cough up some extra
materials to focus their drops leads to
less clutter more useful rewards and
better payout now here's the best part
of trials right now without a doubt
battlely the anti-cheat system is doing
what it's advertised to do and it's
looking real nice i'm sure there's some
cheating scum doing their damnedest to
get around destiny 2's anti-cheat but as
of right now i cannot tell you how
relieving it is to get killed and go
damn great snipe instead of having no
choice but to second guess and go
maybe they have wall hacks having games
go down to the wire for one team or
another to win always ends in either the
team going damn fair play that was a
really good game or just emphatic
shouting if you pull off the dub you
have to understand how huge that
sentiment is because not too long ago
getting stomped in trials felt like a
self-fulfilling prophecy you expected to
lose and you just resigned yourself to
it i've spent so much time begging my
friends to join me in trials and
literally no one wanted to do it or they
would go in and just go eh i'm just here
for the weekly bounty cause the game
mode simply wasn't fun that's all
changed now and if you're playing
destiny 2 and always wistfully looked at
the dude rocking the glowing trials
armor in the tower now is your chance to
blaze your own path to the lighthouse
and if going flawless still isn't quite
within reach then is perfectly fine
because now you have every opportunity
and right to still take part and take
home some sweet loot rewards there's a
lot of other popular shooters out there
that are kind of hitting a dip whether
it's from player fatigue or from a
myriad of other reasons like the
incredible amount of cheaters and
warzone but destiny 2's endgame pvp is
in a really nice place right now and
it's only going to get better if you
haven't yet give the game a try you'll
want to be as high of a power level as
possible to access trials but the usual
grind for power is not nearly as
imposing as it used to be and getting up
to speed is faster than ever there's a
whole lot of content in destiny 2 right
now so you'll have something to chew on
for quite a bit as you build your
guardian into a pvp machine make no
mistake the changes made to trials of
osiris are amazing the revamped reward
system is top notch stocking up on
materials actually matters now if you
want to focus your loot drops and the
availability of the mode to solo players
opens up the floodgates to keeping the
player population high a must for an
endgame pinnacle activity that wants to
have enough varied matches there have
been so many uplifting stories on
twitter about people getting their first
flawless and for me personally i made it
to the lighthouse a whopping five times
on pc this weekend compared to only two
times in the last year and i was even
able to help lift several of my friends
who had never made it before and one of
those flawlesses was on a passage of
confidence which for those of you who
know that is ridiculous
dude is that your flawless or what oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah let's go
oh yeah it was without doubt the best
weekend of destiny 2 i had ever played
in my last four years and for someone
with over 2 000 hours in this game
that's saying something
[Music]
you